[Applause]  [Music]  we now have first person intel from  inside the west view anomaly  what are we looking at here is it an  alternate reality time travel  it's a sitcom starring two avengers  that's a working theory well i know the  apron is a bit much dear but i am doing  my best to blend in  hello dear hiya kid hi kiddos  life moves pretty fast out in the  suburbs  i think something's wrong here  should we just take it from the top  wanda wanda  i don't know how any of this started  what is outside of westfield  yeah i'm not sure what that's about it's  probably just a case of the mondays  am i right  is this really happening yes my love  are you crying  but i'm invested  [Applause]  [Music]